by now everyone knows that apk size is
an important factor when it comes to
user acquisition I mean who wants to
wait 30 minutes to download some massive
app on a 2g connection or pay the high
data rates required to download that app
on a metered network my name is Colt
McAnlis and to keep your app from being
one of those data hogs there's some
important tools and tricks that you
should keep up your sleeve at the
corridor reducing apk size comes the
understanding that bloat usually comes
from two key factors resources and code
and since resources can often account
for the largest bloat and is the easiest
to fix we're gonna start there the first
and most important thing you need to do
is make sure that you're properly using
the remove unused resources flag in your
Gradle files this flag will remove any
content that's not being used by your
application this includes anything that
you've forgotten to prune from your tree
and resources that have been included in
third-party libraries but your app
doesn't use secondly most resource bloat
comes from supporting multiple
resolutions in screen densities for your
app I mean as of Android 4.4 the
framework supports ldpi mdpi TV DPI hdpi
xhdpi xxhdpi and XXX hdpi but let's be
clear just because you can support all
these densities doesn't mean you should
have copies of your assets for each one
of them see if you don't have resources
for a specific resolution the framework
will rescale an existing resource to fit
the bill for you so if there is no
noticeable difference between the
resource you're scaling by hand and the
framework resized one you can toss your
custom one out the result is a much
leaner apk that has only the resources
it needs for distribution thirdly we all
know that images account for the largest
footprints so for icons or other small
simple graphics in your app you might
want to take a look at vector drawables
instead of PNG s or JPEGs these are
assets that describe the shape of your
graphic using XML instead of just raw
pixels the result is that instead of
keeping around one version of your
drawable for each supported resolution
you instead can use one file and it'll
generate the resolution you need at load
time fourthly try to reuse resources
wherever possible Android provides
several utilities to modify an existing
asset in layout code which could you
could use to get the look you
without having to include a whole new
unique image for example let's say
you've got two images that are just
rotations of each other you could get
rid of one by just creating a rotate
drawable to create the other now while
these may sound like small changes they
can yield a significant savings for your
apk for example the android framework
team was able to use color tint support
then go and replace nine patches with
xml shapes and then replace bit naps
with vector drawables the result their
apk drawable count shrunk by 80% now
once you get your assets in a smooth
state it's now time to make sure that
your code is as slim as possible see
even though code bloat is not as
problematic as resources remember when
you're downloading things on 2g every
bit counts now once again your first
step is to make sure that your use of
ProGuard is being done correctly to have
code removal simply set the minified
enabled flag to true in your Gradle
settings this will signal ProGuard to do
all the heavy lifting when you want to
compile your app oh yeah we did a video
on that if you want to learn more next
up try to optimize code which is
responsible for generating other code
there's lots of things like enums and
protocol buffers which can result in an
increased number of methods and classes
inside of your Dex file thus causing
bloat as such make sure to have a keen
eye or in some cases a flamethrower to
tune and optimize this type of code as
it can reduce the amount of code that
gets generated from it finally take a
hard look at libraries you've included
in your application some libraries
especially those designed for the server
or the desktop environments come with a
whole lot of objects and methods that
your Android app just doesn't need now
to be fair pro-gard helps solve part of
this problem but it can't fix everything
since some of these libraries can have
big internal dependencies that pro card
just can't remove not to mention that
for these large libraries this type of
probe our optimization can come at a
great cost of taking longer to compile
as such always make sure to try to find
a tiny mobile-friendly alternative
version of the library you need and if
that fails you could always just extract
the functions you need from the library
and put it in your own codebase if
you're willing to do that anyhow the
most important in all of this is
properly splitting your apk see there's
some content that is bundled into your
apk we
all users have to download but only some
so portion will ever use like having a
small screen device download a
high-resolution screen content to fix
this the Android platform allows you to
split content into different apks based
on things like apk levels screen sizes
and GPU texture support this way devices
with specific screen sizes won't receive
assets from sizes it won't use although
be warned that this does come with a
little extra overhead to build and
deploy oh and as as of Android studio
2.2 there's a really fancy new built in
apk analyzer which helps you understand
the contents and the sizes of different
components in your apk it gives you
direct access to see what's being
included it sizes and help you figure
out what's needed to make them smaller
see at its core making smaller apks
makes faster downloads which makes
happier users which makes happier
developers so make everybody happy err
by checking out the rest of the Android
performance patterns videos and don't
forget to ask the tough questions on our
Google+ community so keep calm profile
your code and always remember perf
matters
you